[Musique]
grand succès du temps des fêtes ce sont
les nouveautés technologiques avec nous
pascal forget qui est chroniqueur à
planète techno sur ici explorant bonsoir
passe quelque chose c'est toujours un
bonheur de vous recevoir c'est comme si
on était des enfants devant devant s'est
joué là et je sais que ça intéresse
beaucoup beaucoup de gens
on y voit tout de suite les écouteurs
sans fil oui je pense avec un beaucoup
d'écrans son fils vont être sous les
sapins cette année il ya entre autres
rapports qui a lancé les impôts du poro
une version qui intègrent l'annulation
active de bruit donc c'est non seulement
des écouteurs qui vont sonner bien
qu'ils vont sonner mieux que les 1 pas
du tout court mais qui en plus vont
annuler les bruits ambiants donc son nid
dans les transports en commun sont et en
avion en voyage on va entendre très bien
sa musique et sa voix atténuer les
bruits autour et on peut faire les
appels téléphoniques l'autonomie est
excellente coûte 300 quelques dollars
donc ce qu'est ce qu'ils aiment les
produits apple sont habitués et payer un
petit premium pour l'expérience à bord
pour ceux qui ont les appareils android
ou qui vraiment un peu moins cher
kelly jabra 75 des pourris plus petits
qui se glisse dans les oreilles qui ont
sensiblement les mêmes propriétés cette
heure et demie d'autonomie entièrement
sans fil donc ces deux petits bouchons
dans les oreilles ils ont pas
d'annulation de bruit mais vont quand
même permettre d'écouter sa musique très
confortablement des ca va etre bien
agréable ceux qui ont des enfants qui
sont gamer qui se disent les petits
trucs on va les perdre les briser il ya
des écouteurs pour les gamers comme le
high peaks qui on voit ici il ya une
espèce de micro 6 2 mais devant qui se
détache ah bon alors si on veut se
déplacer dans la rue on peut se promener
comme ça et le truc secret se dire aux
ados qui veulent pas porter de trucs qui
gèle les oreilles les enfants avec ça
ils ont les oreilles au chaud croyez moi
et on peut s'en servir pour faire du
gaming le micro sert à parler ses
coéquipiers et se faire bien entendre ce
qu'on collabore dans les jeux donc on
peut s'amuser avec ses lunettes haut
parleurs ça c'est quelque chose qui est
très particulier parce que comme les
téléphones n'ont plus de prise
d'écouteurs ce que le sans fil est
vraiment la tendance
il accompagne metrics la compagnie bao
aussi qui fait des lunettes qui intègre
des haut-parleurs les essayer ou est
tout à fait et donc si magique c'est que
même si autour on n'entend rien on n'en
tire pas mal
la musique c'est pas évidemment pour les
audiophiles l'on s'entend que c'est pas
ça remplace pas des écouteurs très
coûteux oui mais ce qui est fantastique
disons qu'on entend légèrement on entend
déjà c'est ce qui est magique faut
vraiment l'essayer ce voyez quelqu'un
qui en a l'effet magique qui sur une
terrasse vous êtes laissa entendre votre
musique pour les gens qui font du sport
pour des gens qui sont sur la plage qui
vont en voyage vous écoutez votre
musique tranquille vous enlevez vos
lunettes les musiques vous n'entendez
plus il ya des micros intégrés qui
permettent d'écouter aussi de faire des
appels téléphoniques avec ses lunettes
simplement
l'inconvénient c'est que sont les portes
la nuit c'est comme si c'est paris c'est
merveilleux
les assistants personnels avec aiguille
l'an passé là on n'a pas vu beaucoup
beaucoup d estaing google oui avait pas
d'écran
cette année on a non seulement des
instants avec des écrans mais on s'est
toutes questions tous ses sens
visualiser le sapin l'instant personnel
alexa venait d'arriver et par maintenant
français donc les et sans alex les
instants et coup et on y parle français
avec regarder l'on voit les choses c'est
plus juste quand on demande la météo on
voi informations affichées sont venus
voir vidéo on le voit à l'écran sont
pose une question on voit la réponse on
peut contrôler sa domotique est ce que
je peux lui demander la meilleure
émission de télé oui vous vous demandez
vous
vous commencez par alexa alexa quelle
est la meilleure émission de télé
sans aucun doute la voie à bella par
exemple non on met sur son trente ans
m'avait cadeau j'ai pas choisi les
réponses faits auxquels la pression et
c'est le haut parleur connectés sonos
m'ouvrit ça c'est quelque chose de
fantastique parce que une année où les
haut parleurs connectés blue tout était
à la mode celui là est connecté par le
réservoir faille de sa maison dans huit
cantons soit un appel quand on sort de
la maison la musique continue de jouer
pour les gens mais ce qui est
fantastique c'est un appareil
d'accompagner sonos qui en fait depuis
plusieurs années qu'ils étaient branchés
dans le mur celui là on peut le
débrancher on peut le déplacer il se
pose sur une base donc l'écouter
partisans la maison et l'emmener sur la
terrasse les restants étant perry fait
même si simplement sa terrasse produit
laisse il va très bien résisté il coûte
combien
c'est presque 500 $ 500 mais c'est tout
c'est assez de qualité la qualité sonore
est impressionnante et ça sert aussi de
haut parleur bluetooth donc son sort de
la maison pour vais l'écouter en
technique on peut l'écouter mais à la
maison il faut se connecter à votre
réseau en f1 et ça va fonctionner
contrôleur ce qu'a dit ah oui ça c'est
pour les gens qui veulent jouer
le contrôleur c'est à dire c'est juste
mais lui par exemple le contrôle en
stage est ce que ça permettra aussi joué
avec son téléviseur avec son téléphone
sa tablette
la magie c'est que le traitement du jeu
se fait un peu comme avec netflix
premier film se fait dans les nuages
c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin d'une console
branche à la télé on peut commencer sa
partie avec cette ligne un petit
adaptateur et on peut jouer avec le
téléphone qui est ici donc dans les
transports en commun c'est fantastique
on arrive à la maison on se connecte à
sa grosse télé toujours avec la même
interface
c'est un abonnement mensuel et il faut
acheter les jeux mais c'est des jeux de
qualité c'est pas des petits jeux
simples conférences mettront peut
vraiment jouer à des jeux complexes avec
des aventures avancer et surtout les
graphismes super de qualité
téléphone pixels 3 ouais ça c'est pour
ceux qui veulent un téléphone prochain
les langues ya évidemment la réforme qui
va être assez coûteux le pixel 3a est
une version prochaine je pense que
c'était malheureusement il lui faut
c'est à dire 25 ans et ce qui est fait
est fait
le record des très très belles photos
qui ont pris l'appareil photo de
l'appareil haut de gamme
ils l'ont eue dans un appareil beaucoup
moins cher donc si vous voulez un
appareil moyen a pris vraiment pas cher
autour de 300 quelques dollars mais qui
prend les traits très belles photos le
pixel 3 à 1 3a excellent qui est un peu
plus group prend des très très belles
photos ici les gens en bourse le routeur
les routeurs mayenne est wi fi avec tous
les dirigeants disent ah ouais tous les
gadgets maintenant dans la maison ça va
peut-être le temps de remplacer ses
routeurs la maison parce qu'un seul ne
suffit plus
plutôt que de voir un routeur qu on le
cache un peu parce que c'est un truc
plein dans un tempo très joli les
routeurs robe comme ça on appelait ça
avec les fils et l'autre en place
ailleurs dans la maison et donc ça
relais le signal et ça permet d'étendre
la portée du signal partout dans la
maison
ça fait une énorme différence la vitesse
reste concentrent dans toute la maison
et ce qui est fantastique c'est aussi un
assistant gougaud donc en plus parler à
son routeur et lui poser des questions
ce si google s'est pas amazon d'être que
les réponses sont meilleurs mais pas les
deux
alors évidemment pour penser qu'il ya
une prise électrique qui se branchent
ces appareils la wii ces deux appareils
sans fil mais ça prend quand même une
prise électrique ayant un café branché
dans votre modem à la maison c'est
vraiment une grosse différence pour
améliorer son bfr et la neige et vous
avez une montre solaire oui ça c'est un
retour au bon vieux temps les gens
trouveront trop tendance à regarder
leur avec leur téléphone ouais et donc
se mettent à distraire parce que tu
regardes le téléphone votre tour un
message instruite la compagnie solio
c'est une banque qui se veut éco
responsable de conception québécoise
même l'emballage c'est fait avec du
carton dans lequel y ait des graines on
peut le présenter
on peut choisir le bracelet on peut
choisir le corps de la montre la couleur
et tout se veut éco responsables ils
vont choisir des fournisseurs les métaux
qui sont bien utilisés et c'est un bel
objet on peut acheter plusieurs
bracelets l'échangé s'est dressé les
standards de montres ces courriers c'est
à peu près 300 quelques dollars mais
stop et s'est fait au canada
c'est ça le sait sa conception
canadienne
je pense qu'ils font des partis à
l'étranger mais ça se veut une belle
conception de montréal et on était
distrait par son téléphone quand on veut
voir la wii c'est sain quelques secondes
2 d'exposition à la lumière fait qui
fonctionne pendant des mois pour ne pas
besoin de passer dix heures elle mettre
au soleil on dit alors c'est tout c'est
presque tout qu'est ce que je voulais
aussi mentionné avec le petit support
pour les produits ont tellement envie
tout simplement l'an passé je vous ai
parlé du petit spork écossais web et
quoi encore une fois debout dézingue
très résistant très solide et de tenir
son téléphone ce nouveau modèle plus
précis pour mettre son téléphone et on
peut le mettre sur soi et l'autre chose
aussi peu d'intérêt qui a terminé sous
les galaxy foot qui s'ouvre il se
transforme en tablette
donc on a un écran à l'extérieur tu es
si on loue c'est beau c'est combien
ai-je été sage cette année oui mais je
sais pas si je mérite ça on risque
d'avoir beaucoup l'an prochain ses
débuts merci merci fantastique très
intéressant